[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الصغار في فصل دراسي عادي ،
بالكاد يبدون مثل النشطاء
العاديين لديك على الرغم من أن هؤلاء
الأطفال يأملون في تغيير عالمنا بإنهاء
عبودية سامة لكل منهم
تعني الحرية  شيء مختلف ولكن
بالنسبة لنا جميعًا ،
فهذا يعني أن كل شيء تعني الحرية بالنسبة لي
القدرة على الابتكار والمشاركة ،
الحرية بالنسبة لي تعني وجود
روتيني الأساسي لحقوق الإنسان بالنسبة لي هو الحق
في التحدث بحرية ، لا تقلق بشأن
آليات السلامة الخاصة بي التي تساعدنا أكثر
فهم هذه المشكلة لأنها وضعتنا في
مواقف معينة وجعلتنا نفكر فيها ،
ولكن إذا كنت طفلاً بلا
حرية ، فالأمر متروك لكم يا رفاق ،
بقدر ما يعود الأمر لمؤسسة مثل
CNN لرفع مستوى الوعي ببعض
أسئلتنا  تشبه
مناظرات عروض الألعاب أو قوانين العمل في أي بلد
لأنه لا يوجد حول
الطلاب هنا الذين يخططون لإحداث
فرق في العام الماضي ، تركز معظم هذه
العقول الشابة على حرية ذلك  إذا
فقدوا منازلهم هذا العام ،
فقد كان الأمر أقرب كثيرًا إلى المنزل ، والحرية
لمجرد البقاء آمنًا في الفصول الدراسية ، واحدة
من تلك التي أعتقد أنها صدمت الكثير منا على
الفور عندما حدث ذلك ، لم يعد
الهاشتاغ مرة أخرى ، هل يمكنك تخمينه في
الحدائق  فلوريدا 14 إصابة 17 حالة
وفاة خمنت أنها تشاهد ميدان رماية
لن يحدث هذا مرة أخرى أبدًا شارك
معنا طوال اليوم أينما
تشاهد في العالم بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن
أبو ظبي